you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
wildfires in siberia this summer have
produced more greenhouse gases than
germany does in an entire year
the 1980s environmental agreement
reducing the impact of climate change
today
and sweden's highest mountain shrinks
because of a melting glacier
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
as fires burned around the world this
year at a record-breaking rate skies
turn to red and vast landscapes were
blanketed with a thick smoke
now this picture by nasa shows the smoke
across the republic of sakha in russia
and now data shows the carbon emissions
created by these wildfires and although
europe has suffered some of its worst
fires in decades it's parts of russia
where fire emissions are dramatically
greater than the rest of the world
well we'll look at that data in just a
moment but first let's remind ourselves
of where those fires are well
firefighters are waiting to contain
multiple fires that are burning in
france spain and portugal today now
these are the latest areas around the
mediterranean to be affected by fires
and in the past few weeks we've seen
fires across greece algeria spain and
turkey it's also the same for large
parts of western u.s in particular
california where the state's second
largest wildfire has been raging since
july
well heat waves and drought have fueled
fires in siberia too this summer in july
we reported from the gorney district
where temperatures of 39 degrees
intensified the conditions there
meanwhile this chart shows the level of
carbon being emitted from wildfires
around the world and you can see the
yellow line which shows that from 2016
carbon generated by wildfires in the
sakura republic of russia started to
increase and this year has reached more
than 200 megatons with other areas
canada the us and the mediterranean
including europe much further behind
in fact emissions from siberia this year
alone are equivalent of some
953 megatons of carbon dioxide
that's far greater than germany's
greenhouse gas emissions for an entire
year which itself has the highest
emissions of any european country
well let's bring in then our moscow
correspondent diana magnay now so diana
give us an idea of the extent of the
wildfires there this summer diana and
what's the situation like now
so it's a record-breaking year more than
2012 which was the biggest year on
records for wildfires before and it's an
astonishing statistic the siberian
wildfires or fires across russia have
burnt a larger area than all those other
wildfire hot spots that you mentioned so
all of those combined are less than
what's burnt in siberia which is why
those emissions are so huge and it's not
just because of abnormally hot weather
and very little precipitation it's also
because of forestry mismanagement and
there is still quite a big practice of
uh burning for agricultural purposes in
russia which can uh catch fire uh to
forest uh and and have and and start
wildfires that way um russia
also tends to only focus in terms of
firefighting on those wildfires which
are near human habitation because this
is such a vast
area and siberia is largely uninhabited
which means that huge wildfires are
allowed to burn unchecked they really
can't get near them and they can't
possibly fight them and that also
contributes to uh this problem and that
is why you're seeing the the fires at
the scale that we're seeing them and
with the kind of emissions we're seeing
them because as they burn unchecked of
course huge amounts of carbon are
released into the atmosphere the
permafrost on which much of siberia and
this coniferous forest there is based uh
starts to melt releasing carbon into the
atmosphere too and smoke from the fire
starts to coat the snow further north
which has a very bad warming effect too
so it all contributes
diana thank you
well we'll be joined by the expert
behind that wildfire emissions research
next but first let me take you over to
our data dashboard which shows how many
tons of co2 has been emitted in the
world since records began you can see
the figure down here and that number
ticking up constantly as you can see
well joining us now is mark parrington a
senior scientist at the
ecmwf copernicus atmosphere monitoring
service that's a weather forecasting
group in europe
so welcome to you now we do see
wildfires every year don't we across the
world but are they any more widespread
this year globally and what does that
mean for their carbon footprint
that's right we're seeing fire a lot of
wildfires and well open burning also
that they're not always wildfires
because they're often set for
agricultural purposes um around the
world every day um in the summer months
we expect to see wildfires in the boreal
forest in siberia and in north america
but what does stand out this year
particularly in the sakai republic is
just the real um scale and the
persistence at which they've been
burning at high intensity we've been
monitoring these fires essentially since
the middle of june
and only now in recent days does it look
like there might be some abatement in
their activity and how do you explain
why those fires in russia are
particularly bad
um so one common feature of these
wildfires in in russia but also in north
america and those around the
mediterranean we've been seeing is there
occurring where there's been much drier
conditions and when heat waves come
along this is increasing the
flammability of the fuel that's how
ready it is to burn so that when there's
an ignition
the risk of a fire starting is much
higher and the scale at which they can
burn is is clearly much higher as well
and it's not just the carbon emissions
that are cause for concern is it what
about the particular matter that they
give off as well how worrying is that
this is very concerning this is one of
the the clear direct impacts of these
fires on is on air quality um wildfire
smoke consists of particular matter but
also a wide range of very hazardous and
toxic gases which are very unpleasant
and which
would add you know quite a lot of air
pollution on top of
um already existing pollution sources in
urban environments and indeed in some of
the cities down winds of these fisa cuts
for example in siberia or athens in
greece have all had advisories
for air quality and degraded air quality
in recent weeks
mark harrington thanks very much indeed
thank you
in today's other climate news
environmental groups are calling on the
fishing industry to do more to
decarbonize the sector a report led by
wwf estimates that uk fisheries emit the
same amount of co2 as a hundred and ten
thousand homes over a year it says that
measures need to be introduced to
protect carbon stored in seabeds and
preserve marine life the fishing
industry says it's taking steps to
address environmental concerns
the national trust says more funding is
needed to protect the lake district's
landscape from erosion the fix the fell
scheme says the area is rapidly being
destroyed as a result of an increasing
number of visitors to the area during
the pandemic nearly 10 million pounds
has been spent to repair footpaths and
protect wildlife since it was set up in
2001.
and sweden's last remaining mountaintop
glacier is at its lowest height since
records began the southern peak of
kebnerkaiser mountain was measured at
2094 metres above sea level by
researchers from the tafler research
station scientists at stockholm
university said it's losing height due
to rising air temperatures and changing
wind conditions
and you can see more on that story on
our website which tracks how glaciers
are shrinking just head over to
skynews.com
climate
now more than 30 years ago the world's
leaders came together to sign the
montreal protocol an environmental
agreement banning production and use of
cfcs that were damaging the ozone layer
more than 30 years later a study in
nature has said that this treaty has not
only started to heal the ozone layer but
has reduced the impact of climate change
already a number of countries have
signed an international agreement the
montreal protocol
where there is no cfc alternative good
housekeeping and better priorities will
keep emissions down
[Music]
the eu generated more electricity from
solar power in june and july than ever
before new data from the think tank
ember estimates it accounted for 10 of
the total energy produced in the region
new records were also set in eight eu
countries including spain and germany as
the production and use of solar panels
increased
well let's take a look at how we're
faring here and this line at the top on
our data dashboard shows us where
electricity in great britain is coming
from today and you can see there 37 is
coming from fossil fuels we've got 44
from renewables which includes of course
solar power and we've got 19 coming from
nuclear
and finally six-year-old alicia guardia
from nottingham is riding 50 miles on
her scooter to help save the amazon
rainforest proving that we can all do
our bit to tackle climate change
hello my name is alicia
and i am six years old i am scooting 50
miles over my summer holidays to raise
money for cooler
i have raised nearly 2 000
pounds in just over two weeks
[Music]
i am writing letters to important people
to ask them what they are doing about
climate change
here's a letter from the queen
here's a letter from boris johnson
his letter from sergey vidalia
[Music]
climate change is important to me
because without the rainforests all the
animals
will die we only have one earth
so we need to look
after it
[Music]
and so far alicia guardia's scooting
challenge has raised more than three
thousand pounds on the just giving page
so far
well that's everything from us for today
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]